and we are live welcome to punch young
sports we're winners win life I am back
in the saddle you are welcome
okay join me you know who we are you
know we're here to do my good friends
both of them we got a Jason hambone
Tebow Thank You Johnny powerless what
I'm feeling you forgot your name
happened again dates all the gates who
are you gonna be Jason I'm gonna be at
the comic store Sunday doing your show
yeah or Kevin Lee light a little benefit
for our good friend Hollywood Jesus who
passed away all the proceeds are gonna
go to that Sunday The Trevor Project yep
so today eight o'clock main room comics
remaining room great lineup I'll be
there for that that 12th which is next
Wednesday Tuesday whatever that is
Thursday I will be at the Harbor comedy
club and I'm also at 40 so suck my dick
it's that club stinks like now twitch or
anything like that nothing you want to
tell them where you live where there's
meth Jewish people walking robot your
address math Alta Vista Boulevard north
AltaVista Boulevard West Hollywood I'm
on the corner of Santa Monica and
Western if everyone's that's [ __ ] yeah
dude guys
next weekend which is April 13th 14th
and 15th I'll be at the La Jolla Comedy
Store with Brett Tim bilko and David
Deary and then the big big big big big
big show is June 1st at cops in San
Francisco myself Eddie Bravo Ryan Davis
and other conspiracy theorists will be
doing the tinfoil hat comedy night
brought to you by I brought to you by
live news at you know the June 1st
gingka June 1st that's a Friday then
June 2nd is
we'll be doing at the sacramental punch
line
they'll be June 2nd now here's the thing
we're going big on the cops 1 what we're
doing is we're doing a stand-up comedy
about comedy and conspiracies then we're
doing about a 30-minute like QA at the
end with everybody in the show you could
ask your questions we'll answer them
live on stage and then what we're doing
is whoever brought the most people
because we have to sell we need 200
people to bring one friend whoever
brings the most people get to come
backstage with us smoke weed and do a
private podcast with Eddie Bravo myself
Ryan Davis in the green room so you guys
come hang out if you love tinfoil hat
you gotta come support this cuz Live
Nation will put all over the Nate all
over the road so guys check that out and
I am glad to be back clever scheme it's
very smart yeah I just got a pack that
first those first two and then Live
Nation says they'll put us on the road
and it's gonna be like you ever see what
they did I like the blue collar tour
where they all say on stage and he's
just answered all the questions and
talked I missed that one I'm afraid to
know if from North Carolina you didn't
see that one of the greatest histories
in a redneck comedy of all time I didn't
have at Jeff Foxworthy CDs I have to say
when I was a kid come on you had the
girl I mean whoever brings most people
to see me at the harbour comedy club on
the 12th I will live with you if you can
bring one person I will live with you
for five years if you bring two people
you're gonna have to kill me to get me
to leave so I only recommend bringing
one that I would appreciate it if
somebody did that I don't know where Ari
is he's been really busting my balls we
started a little late coming we had
trouble getting here and so I was
texting we're a little late and he just
went bonkers you remember what you were
really in LA I think he's in a mood you
remember when you were younger and you
would be trying to oh look at that shirt
speaking of rednecks blue or blue I like
that all right looks like you like that
shirt all right looks like he's going
hunting for [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh nice
do you guys remember when you were young
and like a chick would be like yeah okay
come over let's hook up you knew you
had like five to ten minutes to get
there before she would change her mind
like you couldn't get anywhere in five
minutes where I came from says well you
just had to get there quick before she
changed her mind cuz that was the Holies
always thing get there
what is the farthest you've driven for
sac or she's like tires that car yeah
I'm tired like [ __ ] she's gonna fall
asleep five three hours yeah
really yeah three you drove three hours
my drove from one University to another
University I drove 50 miles I drove from
Ball State University to Miami of Ohio
how long did that take though like ten
minutes well it was like and it's
literally from one end of Phoenix just
guns yeah I imagine back in those days
when you drove 50 miles you had to stop
every mile to check your pager
this is pulling over and every pay phone
what's up bro can't talk right now going
applause the addiction was in this if
you have a patient never had a pain I
never had a patriot
alright you ever have a pager re re
walked off years did you really I'm
still like no I got a page my agent
would text me
I own audition so I act like go find a
pay phone and [ __ ] call him are you
serious yeah then he started abusing it
he keeps he paged me 911 one and I'd
pull over out of [ __ ] trying to find a
payphone on the highway get off the
highway like what he goes don't leg off
your turn I'm Lorent are hey re do you
have any dates how the gates yeah I'm
going Australia when do you go on Monday
yeah for a month yeah I mean I'll be
Albany in Syracuse on Wednesday Thursday
but then I go for about a month go to
Perth 13 to 14 then I gonna they're
gonna Melbourne for a week and I got a I
delay then Sydney then Brisbane yeah
then I'm back hey 607 my people my clan
go see re at destiny mall and Syracuse
through the mall named after a stripper
it's I love that room the people are
cool that that's one of the coolest
staffs out there I have to Syracuse
funnybone yeah they're very nice dude
they're very cool I love it a lot
Oh ours giving us a different look at
his trophy [ __ ] cabinets down but it's
always there the old trophy cabinet hey
guys I wanted to talk to everyone
the Johnny Woodward Johnny Woodard or
however you want to pronounce it
depending on what part region of the
country depending on whether you can
read or not Johnny is working really
hard on are you our YouTube channel he's
been uploading all your classic all
puncturing classic fights and we got a
bunch of walkout videos so everybody's
loving them listen if you loved it if
you look if you love the podcast go
subscribe to the YouTube channel it's
punch-drunk sports we're gonna start
building that up doing some live stuff
now my question thing is here's a thing
so apparently all things comedy did not
like the amount of nudity
let's not place blame on anybody but
like such people in the podcasts have
nudity we did [ __ ] a doughnut [ __ ] we
did [ __ ] a donut why when I are totally
innocent but it is 99% his wings so I
was one for days we [ __ ] isn't even 1%
is it like point zero one percent 7
years I [ __ ] one donut with my little
nub yeah I mean there was a couple
episodes where Ari and I had or naked or
had our pants off for the majority but
it is ok hey hey guys what are you
eating our sorry what are you eating
well I mean is the big news April 1st
live it actually is up it is up he's
alive
is it there yeah only yeah you have to
have the link but I like it's in certain
people are testing it I've sent the link
to certain fans and they are testing it
and whether they say I have it's only
made a couple look I can't tell you the
link because I don't want a thousand
people going there right now yeah we're
just we're it's being it's it is up but
it's being tested that can clear this up
yeah it'll be up in two weeks but the
YouTube channel is rockin it's doing
great Johnny you're killing it the
patreon is killing it everybody's loving
the patreon is really good it's been on
fire lately
I had Duncan Trussell on if you like
yeah it was great where he told me to
come out of the closet and guess what I
listened to him I sucked a bunch of
dicks over the weekend I think I've
never been happier
you look happy looking happier it looks
good I'm never dude it's like I didn't
know fight how much I would love
unlocking my jaw and just guzzling and
it's just I feel better you feel better
you know I wish you would have said
something earlier cuz I would have saved
me a lot of therapy and upset and drunk
breathing it loads blasted on you all
over the way night on your eyes I love
it skin looks great thank you dude it's
a fully you've never looked so re I've
been hitting up I've been hitting up
Luis Gomez going hey can we do a punch
run podcast that's gang fest and I never
get hit back from them
I understand website as the guy running
scaring fast can you make any calls on
that you have any breaking news for us
re I love when you eat on this show it's
so easy to understand yeah yeah yeah
more green in your teeth please yeah if
you're gonna arch be calm skank best you
can find always take this news oh ha
this coming week we already almost sold
out all the presale tickets this is
where you go for website not but Luis is
Gomez his fake site but my real site
side out again and I'll be telling you
guys about new bookings that we have
that you can only find out about at Ari
Shaffir common requests are not Louis
just fakes I only made their honor for
me to announce it not Louis yeah yeah
what's that site again are yes you said
there's monitoring us that's our new
sponsor so uh so are you [ __ ] your
own escape escape s if we see Louis
didn't control it right so I'm really
taking over and bringing it to a new
generation do you have news about
punch-drunk announced about about
unlike that picture on the other on the
right side of the screen can you
maximize that he's trying he's trying
but look at that look at that boss who
is like are jacked Ari Shaffir whoa are
you so shredded you'd never wear that
hat let's be honest yeah well not in
America
so dude so what are the dates on cake
fest so I can put all it in my calendar
for life
third twelve thirteen thirty it's your
life and I just like to say this right
now guys I don't I don't do this much
but breaking news breaking news that's
breaking news with Ari Shaffir and 15
this year you heard it here first
your one true source for skate best news
Ari Shaffir oh I'm really nervous to buy
my [ __ ] tickets out heads dead yeah
I'm very nervous I'm very nervous I'm
very nervous
I wouldn't be right now pretty official
comedy jerk one the punch-drunk at City
Ballet bracket
congratulations him you get a free lead
you got a free free pass just gank fast
oh can we give him two that's a goddamn
[ __ ] bring somebody that's a goddamn
bargain his entry by the way was called
Ari's balls are weird
congratulations so he want he was in the
99.9 percent Isles in 99.9 so he went
really funny really well now you did the
bat was a nice shot yeah thanks what was
i I didn't I couldn't even find it it
was so far now on our group yeah the
tournament challenge I know I was at one
point in time maybe when we're down to
like the Elite Eight I was like 9
million something in the country and I
was like oh I turn this around now
granted all my Final Four pretty much
weren't in the Final Four
except for Villanova but I didn't have
them win
whole thing can the chicks who got
pregnant after the Super Bowl win get
double pregnant after the Villanova win
like you know have one baby that's four
months old another baby that's like you
really don't know anything about how
yeah doesn't work I love how you guys
took that [ __ ] serious like I really
was asking that [ __ ] question thank
you
one baby now you know what where is the
fight nany she's having the baby right
now I'm the drive over well she wasn't
having it is I talked to her about 11
o'clock last night what yeah but it
happens fast man I guess that's how that
works
breaking news there just had a
miscarriage Hey look as pregnant as you
want to be there ain't nothing a flight
of stairs can't fix am i right guys are
you with me Sam Sam hello Aaron Aaron
Aaron gets it Aaron gets it
yeah he's nodding his head yes that's a
yes from Aaron Aaron saying yeah I agree
with that flights of stairs make sure to
tweet out your excitement about
punch-drunk reparse going fast now we're
not gonna get into it yeah now you're
gonna make it so we don't get in no
already it I just know yeah you know
said he's in charge of I don't know what
you're even remotely worried about
buying a ticket to New York I'm having
nowhere to stay dude
how great was to see the UH the Italian
guy light up [ __ ] the final game too
though
no he's like depictions oh we finally
got a new via listen we finally got an
Italian guy we can get behind depictions
oh did you go see what Jimmy and Joey's
tweets were do you see what they were
saying oh I love garden your family
did you see dice [ __ ] oh yeah
oh I was just about to bring that up God
we this can we read this Instagram is it
still is it still did Sebastian ever
respond is it Andrew Dice clays
Instagram is it yeah yeah there's a lot
of ways where you can go there's no what
a video or what no I'm I'm on his
Instagram okay there's a lot of ways you
can be like there's no way he actually
wrote that because he or which one it's
that the yep they're right they're gonna
read it Johnny oh yeah you want it you
wanna do I can read you wanna do the
bullet over here I have me maybe you got
a pulled up you can see it re they they
have it from this screen I got I got it
I'd be here but I think this all stems
from texting Sebastian back media but is
it this new one that's nothing new
that's not holy [ __ ] how long is that
thing oh this isn't actually the new one
that's an old one that's from like two
days ago
yeah I think there's an older one yeah
but read that one it's so long enough
but he was pretty much one day ago this
it's gotta be it
he pretty much rips on Sebastian calling
him an imposter
he's doing my act if everybody's making
fun of me to my face that appearance on
Jim Norton radio show on Sirius XM was
classic Norton so real about his use
with me and saying loud and clear how I
changed his life that's how I always get
baffled by your Marc Maron podcast
interview the man tried to get you to
tell stories of our time together but
you kept blowing it off of course it was
a couple years ago dummy and nobody was
paying attention it was right at the
beginning of you selling theaters
remember there was a time when you went
to the Venetian in Vegas and you were
dressed in some kind of [ __ ] cowboy
[ __ ]
guess maybe people upset about that dice
image so you went cowboy and the picture
is of him dressed exactly like Andrew
Dice Clay yeah yeah yeah it's just a
couple it's a complete impersonation
told you it was going to happen about 14
years ago dummy it's why I had to let
you go
it was watching me before I could go on
anyway after the Cowboys shirt in Vegas
I still texted you break a leg you never
wrote back remember and that's what he's
so mad we were talking about this in a
text threat all of us and I go the point
of the story is if dice hit you up
please hit him back or don't go through
his don't rifle through his affair all
right didn't you rifle through his
affairs
I did not actually and I was near by his
drawer by his own rifle do any affairs I
was a calmness deception did you rifle
looking for a rifle take your time
eating and let us know when you're
riding was there a gun in the in the
drop is Ricky I like this part too I was
going through a breakup with my son's
mom an excruciating time in my life it
not be down for sometime and that's when
you really started doing the dice thing
when I was down I don't want to add fuel
the fire I love Sebastian I don't want
you to this dude I feel bad it's crazy
crazy it's weird it's weird that a yeah
that it got to that little dick I did
cuz I'm the real [ __ ] deal and your
worst [ __ ] nightmare
happy bunny day XO so how do you think
this is it happy bunny day
does he like get people telling him like
hey Sebastian's talking [ __ ] about or he
didn't talk about you on Marin how do
you know no I know sir bad I know that
dice has had something weird with
Sebastian for a while and like I don't
know this is all how do you think you
finds out about this [ __ ] doesn't it do
you think he's actually going and
listening to Mariner he's getting this
second or somebody listened to it that's
I'm saying I cannot imagine dice wheels
frizzy or some [ __ ] like that
I can imagine anthropologist oh you know
you got a podcast
Sam Tripoli was talking [ __ ] about you
at this point my life I'm like he wasn't
talking [ __ ] about me yeah I'm thinking
uh context or it was just something I
did wrong that they were commenting on
that they're more than welcome to
comment on because they're my podcast
I've really gone I had any more good
away I I've really gotten to the point
where like even if someone goes all this
guy said that about you I don't even get
mad because comics like to just talk
[ __ ] do you know what I'm saying like
you're like and it's just in the moment
it's not nothing set me the thing that
that Joe Rogan said about my podcast
he's like oh you're so funny yeah go
[ __ ] you know all wise you got to talk
[ __ ] about you know it's like it's just
even if they said sure please just a
piece of [ __ ] I wouldn't even get mad
because it's just come on man you can't
even take the mildest criticism on
Twitter I can't no that's different I
don't wanna get if somebody was like
Tripoli's a piece of [ __ ] on a podcast
you would have it yes Oh dr. Brenda no
matter I would not do it if it was a
friend a comic no I'm talking comedians
talking about comedians okay what
exactly that's what I'm talking about
I'm saying if Matt Edgar's read your
piece of [ __ ] on a podcast that you're a
piece of [ __ ] you wouldn't be like bro I
helped you out so much Oh
gave you kicking your chair and that's
how you talk about me someone's making a
like a bold statement to get a reaction
well that's one thing but it sounds like
oh really such a [ __ ] you know just a
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] you know like like
when comics just talk [ __ ] about each
other it's not like it's meant to be a
statement to be heard maybe that's one
thing if it's I'm gonna get murdered on
[ __ ] Twitter by every listener here
but if it's just like you won't yeah you
block them off well I did like we're
making we're saying our re we're about
to sell our most successful shirt we're
making block by Sam Tripoli shirts and
with the Twitter symbol for being
blocked perfect I like that I mean I
know 600 people that would could buy one
of those well I just I would say if you
get blocked by Sam we'll give you a free
one but we would be
bankrupt in about two weeks I think you
only get one if you had been blocked by
Sam I didn't have to show us they even
Bluff I am in order to get one oh I get
that
there's no tweet I get more per week
than the picture of God block by saying
him I guess six or seven of those a week
yeah I did it the people who wear it as
a badge of honor
yeah they're like hey I'm going in now
I'm about to say something to Sam and
get blocked and then I don't see the
tweet and then they come back and I like
see proved it if you're blocked on
punch-drunk a message me I will unblock
you I'm cool oh you just gave yourself a
40 there's no calls no we're not mean
I'm not Aaron springing in the accent
now Aaron spring into action feel free
to give us a call wrong hey buddy
hey real quick do we want to still have
a viewing party on Saturday for UFC then
UFC coming up Holloway could be yeah do
you want to watch do you wanna do a
viewing party whatever you think I'll
make a flyer what always a good
replacement I still care I was fight I
do care about the fight but I don't
think he has much of a chance I didn't
give Tony a chance actually now I think
about it so I don't know why it's much
different you know that's a fourth time
they were supposed to fight Dana said
he'll never make this fight again that's
oh four four with these two guys they'll
never make the fight again Dana's for
guaranteed this is the first time it's
Tony
two and two two more fights he's gotta
make the fight again yeah all right we
got to call it let's see what we got
here this there's no way this can go
wrong huh hang up there we go sorry Ari
we lost them
sorry we accidentally put you on hold so
we hung up on the costumes we have a
caller no now they'll call back they'll
call back do it yet yeah we're doing we
gotta try zoom I'm telling you zoom is
so much easier what is in the new Skype
it's like a different Skype but it's
easier and then like you have like
little boxes where people can appear in
the little boxes like Google Hangouts
yeah but it's just way easier it's way
easier but Tony Ferguson ah Tony for
let's can we look at that you have C
card yeah sure
there's only two fights that give a [ __ ]
about Tony fergus's press release about
his injury like he's due to during a
promo tour right no don't do it dude
we'll do it later at the end of the day
happy is reset I'm reading the press
release he put up a fight
okay they said let me ask you something
you have to [ __ ] [ __ ] do it his guy
doing his ice looks like Seinfeld Rogen
Sandler burr Marin who by the way didn't
have stories about opening for me on his
podcast that's funny because you're only
open for me traveled and stayed in my
home with me yet no stories my point I
don't know why is that Tony Ferguson
big-time comics original comedians they
call back let me say it is pansy boy
dice my opinion you don't have to time
to call me back and I was being cool ass
[ __ ] ass-sucker busy [ __ ] michig
your book that was just to try to keep
me cool now that journalists see you are
[ __ ] dice impersonator and the fact
that you don't show respect to a
worldwide star the king of this [ __ ] I
called him back hey dude dick face
I am from the streets of Brooklyn New
York you are a little [ __ ] Chicago
suburbanite grew up idolizing me you're
they're gonna sit back and let you steal
my identity like a de version of the
real deal
wait bait boy dice weights light weights
I walk under the Comedy Store and see
you on stage I will make what Rogan
determined SIA look [ __ ] nice you are
dressed like a waiter on your book cover
look in your face is like baby boy dice
is taking a [ __ ] in his pants and when
you see me [ __ ] face you're gonna get a
same [ __ ] look and you don't take
your pants you sure go back you wait
Rick face you [ __ ] wait and that's
Tony Ferguson surprise for me Wow Tony
Ferguson's press release is
well now I understand why he couldn't
fight he's very upset about not getting
called back by Sebastian listen dude I
love everybody involved I I grew up with
Sebastian all that stuff I think when
you start talking about people taking
your essence that's when we go look a
little it gets a little interesting
let's just say that he was the most
famous comic and [ __ ] eyes to the
world it's gonna have what's that yeah I
got the card here what what do you want
- can you read the card off uh yeah
it's you know Halloween B we got a rose
Noma Yunus and yoanna yeah GG I was
saying this before but I like that fight
a lot Rose and Johanna I do yeah if I
watch this fight don't have my glasses
on and I'm far enough away from the TV
it looks like a woman is beating the
[ __ ] out of me and I like that a lot
who do you thinks gonna win them a rose
Ivan groves yeah I think rose has her
number
she's all about psych she's all about
like the mental and somebody broke her
and I think but she's a great fight it's
not like she's not technically a good
fighter do you know what I'm saying like
yeah join a champion she is a great
striker so I think it could be
interesting like no it was a fighter who
showed her skill to beat the other one
so like when you're saying there's no
way she could do it again it's like was
it lucky she didn't try to hit like a
homerun off you know he has the dirt she
where were the gameplay to beat her yeah
so she's sure she could beat you wanna
but you want us not sure she could be
rose yeah I mean like it's like what we
see when somebody has this the boogie
woman which I hated that name just call
you the boogie man the boogie woman yeah
that's like really are we doing like you
know Bigfoot like Bigfoot at like what
are we doing we're having [ __ ]
genders in these [ __ ] boogeyman
you're not really the boogie boogie man
you don't really try to convince people
you're the boogie man
yeah you're just so I'm reminiscent of a
bogeyman yeah
does the boogie man know he's the boogie
I'd say the girl you don't want to fight
the one that has a nickname the petri
dish that's a great boy or date you
don't want to get in a triangle with top
instinct wah oh yeah oh yeah
someone asked me if I was asking means
what a white trash white trash name with
a black father someone's trying to ask
me who I'd rather bang I'd have to go
roast right oh yeah I don't want to cuz
otherwise it looks like you're just
[ __ ] Tony Hinchcliffe or the [ __ ]
yeah but she I think she's got that East
European stink you know what I'm saying
we were like doll I don't know we don't
believe in the author it's ours
I follow her on Instagram she takes a
lot of showers what she does I she's
always gonna shower that's a great
Instagram I recommend she's eating like
rice and [ __ ] she's very healthy what's
the other fight you know they say your
sperm tastes better if you Eli fruit is
that for your snatch to be pineapple I
tell you what that's not necessarily
true because I've tried it both
different ways and I could have a
hundred apples and then drink a cup of
[ __ ] spray downs around smoke and
delicious you call your dick Jamba Juice
well you would think pretending like I
could have a hundred Snickers and it
tastes just don't let you store it up or
do you take it fresh like right out of
spigot oh yeah it's right from the hose
okay yeah yeah that's what they call you
Jason tumbleweed teba yeah my Cano and
Qatar are you okay are you gonna die cuz
we have used the views if you almost
died on the show can we can we took a
kid the three of us have an agreement
that if one of us dies we do it live on
the show like if we're gonna kill
ourselves or anything like that I'm
totally down with that I already said on
this show how I'm gonna kill myself I
figured out the newest way I'm just
gonna zip myself into a body bag and
wait so you're already there well I
you're a bit like I'll eventually die
I might take me a month or two of I
don't know why do you have to be the
body bag though when I use just for
convenience
yeah help those guys that negative show
up and just pick me up I feel like it
would be better for the video stream now
if we yeah that's true oh can we put a
camera in for the patreon in the body
bag so we get like listen to you talk
your way to death yeah that's good I'm
cool I like that so Dave for still here
board is [ __ ] phone died three days ago
times you would [ __ ] yourself before you
died
I'm hoping a lot showers Johanna take it
since I'm up seven more than I thought
she works out a lot man she need showers
man I know what she might hey you say
that's so creepy it's great she takes a
lot of showers I'm just saying she does
not arise I have a lot of faith in her
she's really healthy I feel like you're
rooting for the girl you're apparently
stalking I hope she puts the lotion in
the basket she's the one she puts it all
on Instagram where some other fights mob
so guys Mike so are we gonna do it or
not do you want do to Lush I'm watching
it I don't care well okay so this
Saturday I'm gonna make a fly we put it
out you have see 223 correct live
viewing party punch drunk at the
Sycamore tavern it's on Sunset one block
east of Fairfax anything queer you get
in it is free to get in 7:00 p.m.
Pacific starts yep yep so if you want
come and then Johnny's gonna think about
if he tweaked and livestream it so you
can watch us watch it I got to go down
there and make sure all right so let's
do it are you doing anything tonight
they okay cool so we'll do that so guys
I'm going to make a flyer because I'm a
young Christian warrior and we'll put it
out hope you guys can come and hang out
all right drives you making that fire
well I'll be making that fire on the way
home no he literally did that while
driving he was making a flyer for a
comedy show hey dude if a shark stops
swimming he drowns okay that's right
number three we got some guests we're
gonna bring in
approximately four minutes Renato
Meccano and Kelvin Katara I've been
waiting for this fight for a long time
these guys have been at each other's
throats for a long time I don't know
after that really drops off well that's
why I'm saying there's two fights on
this card I care about what's the fourth
what is it a chiesa and pedis is that
right oh Michael tell Chelsea Chelsea
yeah versus oh that's a good fight dude
that's actually a pretty good fight and
I don't know who the roof work because
they all have bad tattoos usually
Anthony Pettis holy [ __ ] look how far
he's dropped his drops oh do you think
he's happens when you become a
gatekeeper that you have to face all of
the best and a lot of times they beat
you a lot of time you know he's a gate
keeper him and Hendrix both fell off
hard after the testing after the testing
both of them fell off hard okay yeah
that Tigers had she's pretty dope though
I'm getting a tattoo I think this week
really dick I'm getting the punch-drunk
logo on my chest because I love this
black and white no I'm gonna go full
colors like that dude he's lying you're
a lying bastard
what what are you really getting can we
just talk about really getting it fools
the day before April Fool's and like and
mostly that was black people can we talk
about that I have no like they show up
late to events and he do apron I don't
know any by early what's that I'm gonna
hang out with black people's okay okay
but I'm talking like over there too
Anthony Davis from the team unibrow
shaving then that was a day before
yeah and clipper Darrell put it out and
we're like dude you did a day early why
is that why is why do they do that is
that at least that like I like Kwanzaa
is black April Fool's a day earlier than
[ __ ] why April Fool's I feel like we
would have heard about that it was true
that's what I'm just saying a lot of
early April Fool's really looking stupid
are you really gonna tattoo I am
just tell me you're not just gonna go
down there and say yeah just whatever
you want
surprise me I want to get that really
cool black panther that you see as the
first tattoo on the wall are you
culturally appropriating is that what's
about to happen
[Laughter]
who are you can I ask who is this angry
laughs you know what you brought up
getting a tattoo you're not gonna tell
us what you're gonna get that is a good
point
oh [ __ ] I'm getting a tattoo tomorrow
time to bring in our guest what do you
got yeah you're a piece of [ __ ] you're a
piece of [ __ ] to get off the show you
sit in the back
what yeah we're gonna Punk out we find a
bunch of people we take it at the end
the last 30 minutes that's called
[Music]
Direction get justice just a topic for
us to talk about okay well one topic we
could talk about is our good friends at
bet TS I bet D aside for all your
betting needs that's where I go to bet
the side bets dot-com use the promo code
punch 25 and you guys will get us and
anything you put in let's say you put
$1,000 in right you'll get to thousands
in betting cash that's how it rolls bet
dsi probably bet needs I'm gonna do some
I'm gonna do a UFC parlay some boxing
matches some playoffs all coming up the
masters the Masters coming up masters
are coming up Tiger Woods everybody is
exciting by the way does it look like
Nike well okay Tiger we're gonna get you
back in here's some HGH and some [ __ ]
I hop waiter snatch to make you feel
better
some International House of Pancakes ass
to make you feel better about yourself
am i right and that's our good friends
at Betty hi everybody
did I please do it
I lost Kansas overbilled over Oh John
bad you have money on that 40-plus
country 75 bet and then I bet another
whatever I break even if I got one of
them and win money at Cannes the other
one was the over-under on Villanova I'm
sorry I'm Michigan and Loyola and I lost
that one by about four quarters I put
$5.00 on that old lady the nun the old
nun getting pregnant and because it paid
great I paid great I mean listen guys
ah I mean yeah I forgot what he's gonna
say my head just [ __ ] him why bye-bye
oh why don't you sir guess guys joining
us is our good friends David Jack from
ref ratings which is a new app which to
me it seems like I'll let you guys
explain what it is but it gives
accountability to officiating correct
absolutely yeah yeah so what's the name
of bet if it's called the rough rating
yep you can find it on all your app
stores is it out yet no it's not
well right now we're just starting the
beta testing portion of it my cousin
Angela what's your nationality Armenian
yeah there we go
you guys can run Hollywood down we run
the app business okay you want to deal
with [ __ ] go through Glendale apps
[ __ ] you want an app you want to
get pulled out of your car you find us
whoa
oh you want that ball you come through
so panel okay yeah we did bring the
white SUV
we're right oh that's so funny I go do
this no they're like I'm so tired of
Armenian jokes about white guys having
[ __ ] your white SUVs my friend goes you
know you drive a white SUV I'm like okay
[Music]
what are you playing dude what do you
play what's wrong with you cool bro can
I just am blown away by how much greens
all right flip down like I never seen
anything like that yeah hey doing the
audio podcast grazing on our podcast
it's just ridiculous it's offensive stop
playing that song dude or else we'll
disguise
[Music]
Wow such a good sport jack
yeah of course it is so explain us how
your app works
you guys are beta testing now yeah we're
just getting rolling I mean it's a it's
a great opportunity for you know we're
making it for sports fanatics for people
that tune into shows like yours so we're
at a stage where people can actually
have an impact on how this thing works
how it functions how you know everything
won't adjust because people were they
rate ref so rarely ever gonna be like
that was a good call that was a tough
call to make you made it right they're
almost always gonna be like this is
negative so it's just a question of like
this graph got a negative 40 and this
way I forgot a negative 70 so we're
gonna say the negative 70 rec was the
worst one not necessarily because again
it is gonna be bias that's that's
definitely part of it right yeah you're
gonna still get your but if a call goes
in your team's favor you are gonna be
like oh that was a good call you know
like so give it a positive spin but are
you supposed to use this app through the
game so is the game going to be on the
app yeah so we there isn't the video
stream of the game but we're there's a I
think you get in trouble for that right
yeah exactly
but there's a live play-by-play of the
game so kind of like how other sports
app have it you know you see like
play-by-play everything that's happening
in real time except in our app you get
to vote on the plays just a bad call or
a good call it's what's the right call
so we've got customized sports emojis is
it a travel was it a two-point or a
three-pointer blocked charge yeah
everything you can think of is right
there at the tip let me ask you
something how much money did you guys
lose in a bet that you guys said [ __ ]
I'm making this app I've had enough
these guys I'll tell you how crazy these
two were this is actually the brainchild
of my wife and him this is my
brother-in-law right here it's a family
business
he's married a national you should have
seen the wedding I mean you talk about a
culture clash my family's Midwest I got
people coming in from Indiana western
Pennsylvania and they're just sitting
there just we got like troops the
dancers come it was just the ones got
swords yeah read on it there's
everywhere people don't know what's
going on now my favorite part of
Armenian weddings is the Chuck de hummus
at everybody that we do every time when
we grab hummus and we throw it at the
other family did you guys enjoy that
part we didn't do that okay got to
forgive Sam he confuses weddings with
food fights so so what made was there a
particular game that got to equate in an
app to write these guys it wasn't a
particularly my think we just kept
seeing bad calls and we're like why
isn't anybody doing something about this
you know and yeah it happened to a while
it was just like why don't we do
something now they got this website like
ten years ago they've we've been
thinking about this forever
I mean you get think back to 2006 finals
right yeah
Dallas Miami I mean just ripped out of
Dallas his hands game - they had it
there up - Oh Game three the whistle I
mean everybody saw what happened that's
just it's unbelievable it's
heartbreaking people I didn't see it in
the Lakers Kings 2002 it was [ __ ] I'm a
Laker fan maybe I'm biased but Tim
Donaghy and others felt like maybe there
was something to push it to say about
any games
Lakers Boston Game seven where Boston's
up double digits in the second half and
then the the Lakers go to the [ __ ]
line 25 times and the let's zip that
back to 2008 though Game two Leon Powe
has more free throws Leon Powe do we
even know who that isn't he on PO
doesn't even know who he is exactly he's
wandering around somewhere in
Westchester or something
he's got more free throws than the
entire Laker team completely changes
this series mm-hmm we lose that series I
mean that's I mean my my wife was like a
puddle on the floor and blame game for
that maybe I was out to Troy oh it was
Celtics that was like one of the worst
yeah little series of recent memories
yeah I got right that's where Allen went
off that serious right but this it's not
just basketball - I mean look at the
Super Bowl the animation to win the game
on that you know basically when the
games you
for the eagle or even you boxing in MMA
it's it's rampant oh really I mean it's
unbelievable how much so officiating
love changing that [ __ ] you know so
basically what it is is it's like it's
always gonna be I mean I guess you're
saying okay I like that call those that
ref made a great call there right so
it's basically whose fan base is more
passionate and gets on this thing will
vote on who's has but I will I will
admit if I'm watching one of my teams
and it's a decent call or so I'm like
yeah that's the right call
sucks didn't go my way and that's a
tough call to make but yeah that's two
but there's enough out there I mean you
can actually see we've made a like a
feature where you see what everybody
else is thinking about the calls and
stuff and it breaks it down by fan
actually so we got because I was kicking
around with this and and it's actually
what your favorite teams are and all
that sort of stuff
yeah create a profile yeah exactly you
have to create a profile so that we know
exactly kind of like what your bias is
essentially but then once you do that
plus it helps you put your teams on the
top of the schedule and all that kind of
stuff is there something where you know
like when you go to college yeah and you
know they test on a curve they always
throw like the 55 year old like lady
who's got nothing going on who just just
studying all the times gets a hundred
and then they got the guy who can't stop
doing coke and shows up in hopes and
staring off the Asian kid next to him
his [ __ ] test and he bombs out so you
said do you throw out the top meat like
if there's something always like let's
say Tim Donahue's family's always like
like that call like that call like that
call and then there's somebody who like
you know bang Tim Donahue's daughter and
he beat him up so he's like [ __ ] that
guy [ __ ] that guy that guy do you throw
those out like the super top high me top
and the bottom or is it all coming
together so right now we don't have as
much data coming in to see kind of
anomalies like I haven't launched yet
exactly but that's all the kind of stuff
that we're gonna be kind of looking at
in this run so once we start getting the
users in we once we start seeing what
kind of
it comes in that's when we're gonna see
like alright we have to probably adjust
a little bit of this to make it
realistic or more objective all that
kind of stuff but the entire you know
the app itself is working pretty well
is it only um is it only professional
sports right now
are you going into the NCAA's we are do
we go can I get peewee game so I'm like
[ __ ] Tom down the street follow on my
[ __ ] my wife and he's calling my kid
out right now it's just the NBA we're
probably gonna expand into baseball
shortly shortly NFL not yet well open we
have time right because it's you know
until it starts but yeah NFL NHL and
then yeah college as well so will we be
getting into the UFC will we be getting
into WNBA I mean like we're boxing I
think gonna be huge yes guys at limit I
think we want to get into as many sports
as possible I mean soccer is really that
gold mine that's out there I mean it's
just a motion and you look at World Cup
3.5 billion you know for the last world
yeah it's a third of the planet watches
the World Cup yeah yeah for sure I love
when they always like the other the
Super Bowl the most-watched program in
time like not even close the World Cup
and now we got that guy on blows what's
his name Johnny on um slapped on
Ibrahimovic slots on yeah yeah so why
not he goes in good luck he just goes in
and just all world kicks things like two
goals in five minutes I do we gotta go
watch that guy's he's still that jet lag
how much balls is that dude that guy's
gonna [ __ ] everything [ __ ] everything re
sleepy re did you party all night what
happened
okay it's probably that [ __ ] gigantic
salad and dinner you just say yeah nice
Thanksgiving dinner right before but
yeah I mean we're thinking almost every
sport UFC's really excited one of our
favorite sports I mean if you're rating
in between I mean strikes you know your
scores at the end too much [ __ ] you
stick too many stand-ups yeah like that
i watch that Joshua Parker fight Anthony
Joshua oh that guy was the worst that
ref enough I mean he literally stood
standing between them the last 10
seconds he stood in between them
lecturing them like hey can it and like
the clock's ticking at all it's the most
exciting for having a fight it's a close
fight let these guys hit each other how
about when they we get in the inside and
then you just stop they just hold each
other cuz they knew he was coming yeah
you could do anything in sight uppercuts
the the cross you know hits a ribcage
nothing dude did you see in Johnny did
you see that
Wilder too agreed to fight in London all
they did and he said he'd come he'd come
there and fight i rematch clause with
that if it goes too it would be in Vegas
or New York but he's gonna fight him
there what dude I mean you're dumb not
to it's 100,000 people unification have
you eight fights so the first time since
the 90s whoever wins this would have all
five belts well the problem is it's like
and both of them undefeated both of them
undefeated well the problem is this dude
that you're going from London or England
where you're you're fighting in front of
eighty five eighty thousand to what timo
arena that's twenty thought that's what
he doesn't want to do it you shouldn't
do it in a [ __ ] arena
you should find like the Rose Bowl
during the summer and that's where you
should fight where you can put seventy
five eighty thousand people into that
thing to watch a [ __ ] [ __ ] Dallas
down Dallas Cowboys
that's where you go that's what I always
do Oh Tennessee with the Vols play it's
a hundred and five C thousand seats yeah
Michigan like those that's why he
doesn't want fighting cuz unless they
have the Raider stadium done then then
that capacity yeah yeah that one team
that's not even that close to being done
is it no they got another I think maybe
two I thought that's what they're saying
but they're saying they don't they were
cornering if it's gonna be done by then
I can't wait to see I can't wait to see
the LA Rams yeah looks good that was
cool dude it looks cool so how long does
it take for you guys to put a sport into
your app so if you go okay do football
starts in August right boom you have
rake now what five months right yeah we
could pull it off we can we can we can
pull it off in five months for sure you
guys just started the matter all do some
jackers and just [ __ ] go to work more
adderall shoved up your butt go to work
half of it is that half of it is funding
as well though that's right
so it's been basically just self-funded
so far that's why we're kind of limited
to one sport
and when we roll out baseball it'll
probably be just for the local games in
LA and worst just kind of keep us going
but yeah a new sport should take about a
month I think to roll out with if if the
money wasn't an issue I think UFC
I mean MMA because you probably just
want to do UFC and some Bella tours so
those are gonna be unboxing anything at
easiest there any easiest ones that you
could you could do we gloss the right
it's fine let them go we're talking
about this earlier we may do Johnny cat
look at Johnny keys doing Fitness on
there's Aryan over there Aryan who left
a little too hard at that Turkish stuff
okay
ZZZ Inari so I think the UFC is going to
be good because those are like certain
events whereas like every week in
football there's 16 games yes there are
15 games or whatever it is do you fancy
a football just and be an NFL are the
two sports that make controversial calls
you know what I mean
you're a few if you think you're out or
using my databases you're out or safe in
baseball you just look at the replaying
up now up clearly out we made the wrong
call but football and basketball you're
like hey man I said it's a charge you
might not be wise I said pass
interference you might have thought that
was pass interference but it was
whatever right you know their calls that
are just judgment calls we get balls and
strikes you got something constantly
happening yep with baseball as well
right oh yeah steps alright we have
breaking news seriously music honestly
about some breaking news breaking news
Canelo Gee Gee Gee cancel no that's how
that coming but now he's triple G
fighting somebody else he said he would
okay he's gonna fight somebody else he
promised that he would fight somebody
else on the same date find a [ __ ]
dumb [ __ ] lol you know those turning
out to be a giant star it's a couple
weeks ago [ __ ] you guys aren't buying
the Mexican meat I mean I buy that just
as much i buy every Ally Lance Armstrong
said or or everything Jon Jones says
yeah exactly
he's John Jones Lacey's doing yeah Rd
draw around I think that coke could help
your ever done coke you can't run you
can't do it who knows this claw I'm not
sure if you have to do scoops in
still a great fighter it's not gonna
work out for you you'd have to have like
a corner guy with a long nail just go if
you're a coked-up fighting like John you
would tell because John Jones would be
like man stop hitting me I'm trying to
tell you about my screen it's Avery it's
all the golden boys Hong Kong boy your
skull all the golden boy people are all
[ __ ] you know so interesting cos
Golden Boy was not that fighter he was
what like let the last of one of the
greats where he would fight anybody like
they're like oh you want [ __ ] y'all
fight and then they'd fight you're like
whoa you're too small for this guy's I
don't [ __ ] care dawg I'll [ __ ]
fight it Punto and they really need
fighting sometimes he wants sometimes
you lost but he fought everybody now as
a promoter dude I get it I get it that
you know you're like oh if you take some
losses it lose I don't think so I think
I think your fanbase is all based upon
how what kind of fighter you are like do
you put on exciting fights cuz there
were guys in the UFC you know this guy
might win he might Cerrone he's a great
example you're like he might win he
might lose but man you know it's gonna
be a great [ __ ] fight he may not be
able to carry a card but he is gonna put
on great fight so if canal goes in there
bangs with everybody he could always
carry a card even if he loses a couple I
wonder do they say a length of a
suspension Johnny okay I'm here we're
talking he could get up to two years
why is he been bust that means he might
been busted before they always say never
been never had an issue before this so
why would it be two years only the first
one is like a year oh yeah oh yeah I
mean [ __ ] I just want to start the all
drug division of just every combat sport
where it's like no you have to do the
drugs brock lesnar vs john jones every
sponsored by cocaine okay
sponsored by El Chapo okay you mean you
want you want to bring back pride yeah
I'm cool that dude no regulations just
fighter rules and you got to come juste
you have to piss hot
if you don't piss hot you can't fight
guys we're now back to our one of our
more popular segments Ahri's trophy
shell yes I already talked about your
trophy shelf
that's impressive sorry what is the
trophies on top of it mm-hmm always
three trophies shows you got a medal
champion anyway so mm-hmm worst player
best comic trophy game show ah nice
congrats dude congrats cries three
trophies the winner two minutes man
we're almost there last half an hour
calls no yes it costs to out okay can we
do we have any calls
if you want to talk Armenians what do
you want now that he's awake Armenian
specialist you look just like my cousin
I want some so demanding now that he's
awake isn't he yeah of a sudden
someone's not sleeping they got two
bands guys I'm awake now I'm moving
around I need to take home hey are you
getting warm now in New York is it back
to be and find the live in New York
it snowed yesterday oh my dude it's so
hot here chicks are like trying to be
can I take my top off or like if you
have to I'm gonna show you so it'll be a
little better but like [ __ ] it'll be a
lot better yeah Ari do you ever see
yourself moving back to LA I mean less
and less I can see as a possibility but
every time I think about LA I'm like
what garbage people there are there ah
hi I heard that you were saying do we
got a call I was talking to somebody and
they said that you were saying that
they're like our he's never coming back
every time he talks about LA he hates it
it might have been mad at guy I don't
remember was in
my guess is what makes it worse what is
that alright you're on with punch-drunk
sports 6 1 2 holla at your boy so we
called Minneapolis I love Minneapolis my
window we got about six to eight inches
of snowfall right now swimming outside
on Thursday should be good can we do
some fake videos of having huge
earthquakes out here somebody moves here
that's why I do try everybody knows the
traffic's gotten incredibly worse like
it's visibly it's incredible yeah it's
like oh it's a Sunday at noon I'm on the
101 and it's bumper-to-bumper listen
guys television stop they're not hiring
people anymore no more tea
no more movies are made here stay to
[ __ ] home okay the chicks stop putting
out they're all lesbians now there's no
Coke out here nothing's Goods happening
Minneapolis what do you want to talk
about all just wondering if guys are
still in the room hey baby
no when you guys going back to
Minneapolis I saw Sam I met you here
Tripoli or phoebo you just didn't come
with friends easily yeah I did st. Louis
I didn't do hey would you go on our
friends ruff rating app and rate the
refs I was hoping they were going to
start with UFC oh that's that's a good
point
see you guys gotta get in the UFC game
see guys you just got dealt with UFC
yeah we'll get into it hello you're on
with punch drug sports where winners win
or winners win yeah what's the word did
turn your radio on I am not even looking
to add any more to the call your oh my I
was looking to you on my phone now I'm
calling off my phone so okay okay you
think Odell is gonna get treated yeah I
mean depends on what the how much they
can get for my
if you were a team I don't think he does
but I don't think he's gonna be there
Alex I think the writing's on the eye
he's a tireless kind of guy he is a
Dells kind of guy I do strong if they if
they traded them to a division rival I
would be shocked if he goes somewhere
they're gonna try shove them off to the
AFC somewhere if you guys are the Rams
it's over yeah we're bulking up Rams are
good the Rams probably topped four NFL
team right now I think they'll figure
out golf a bit this year I think he'll
come back down to earth but the defense
is gonna and I think I think Rams need a
receiver losing uh Watkins didn't help
they need another guy
Hey Dude put your uh turn off the radio
turn off the radio now I don't think Rob
not hey guys if you call in turn off
your computer your phone cuz we can hear
ourselves and it makes for shitty radio
and posh you put it on mute Ronen
Imboden Ronan and bone and what's up
eight five nine where's that why won't
you spagett ass put a hot dog up your
ass okay okay all right good that's good
that's Guillory thank you thank you for
calling in I love javi that's helped me
a [ __ ] but now with the breakers you
both beat my ass I love that that's a
perfect example of having your
communicator on mute I love it
hey dude why won't you do this gay [ __ ]
you [ __ ] okay that makes sense that
makes a lot of sense the question
where's where's the 859 welcome to punch
on hey why won't your [ __ ] shove
things up your [ __ ] for my
entertainment that's a fantastic point
sir we have a half an hour which is who
knows when that'll be
maybe May who knows when but you're
gonna
there's no ears and I think you're gonna
realize two one oh hello you're armed
with punch-drunk sports and a wide Oh
Blake
Ari Shaffir what's up all right Ari
great idea bringing these phones yes Ari
Ari
look what we do well I like how people
bitched for a year when we couldn't take
calls and then we've been able to in the
new studio no calls or if they do they
[ __ ] it up big hurry are you excited
about the Yankees game are you kidding
me [ __ ] yeah talk about it it's gonna be
an amazing season I mean the offensive
output we're gonna put out if it doesn't
really season with a little start to a
playoffs all that matters for the
records is will we break the homerun
record of 264 home runs last year
without state 241 probably how's your
pitching staff who gives a [ __ ] they're
fine Cece pitch fine okay you know I
wish you'd take more stuff in your mouth
as you talk on the show was drinking or
eating you know hope it'd be great it'll
be great
why don't you why don't you just suck on
a dildo while you're doing it as well I
would actually really like that I mean
if you have a deal I don't have a dildo
on me but surprising sin are you guys
Dodger fans Dodger fans yeah I thought
Yankees are gonna be exciting as hell
though I don't know if you have a game
today you probably get rained out right
yes no doubt on Monday yeah but Dodgers
look good I mean gotta get JT back you
gotta get you know Emily Jensen is
finished ah come on
what three games for your right in 1880
all right it's not it's not terrible you
know what I was hoping is that better
than it's been the Houston Astros would
have invited Dave Roberts to their their
unveiling of their their victory so that
because he's a big reason that they
wanted his in-game analytics and his
notion that we gotta start Godzilla the
pitch in Game seven is he's so clutch
you know because he didn't get lit up
before why else would
just sitting there who [ __ ] them up if
you know you're gonna go to Kershaw by
inning three or four why not put woods
in so any of you gotta use Darvish use
them at the end of the game if you have
to yeah you don't bring in the guy
that's turning green as nervous as
[ __ ] just go oh he's pacing around
doesn't know what he wants to do and you
got this IM winner or whatever who's
just itching to get in the game begging
to go in the game I think dodge is gonna
be fine I think it's too late we lost
the World Series I dropped two grand and
mushrooms on that [ __ ] game too and I
[ __ ] what do you mean you paid for it
with mushrooms or you took mushroom I
took mushrooms at Game two that's never
a regretable why would you all I did was
trip on one all the bad Mexican facial
tattoos I mean they just doodle on their
faces and - how many undercover cops are
were you could just tell who's
undercover cuz that's all that cuz
you're on mushrooms yeah everybody
better cover top when you're on
mushrooms to do is literally like ten
thousand undercover cops at this goddamn
game I don't know well I mean why would
they wait not buy tickets
ten thousand undercover cops everyone
with the entire section undercover cop
they knew they knew I took mushrooms
they knew it was amazing how many
undercover cops and Russian spies were
at this goddamn World Series game so
tall Russian spies undercover cops fill
in a few Mexicans it's so rude dude so
rooted high you're on with puncher and
sparks three one five that is what's
three one five three one five is
Indianapolis Indiana Phoenix Phoenix
Phoenix oh no it's never you Syracuse
hello you're on what's up cues are your
fear will be in your town this week are
your next week I will be there on
Thursday circus Albany guess what
you just got ten free tickets 30 free
tickets dude you have 30 free tickets to
see Ari Shaffir use 30 tickets you take
those resell them for even more make
more money 30 free things
all right how's he get his 30 free
tickets here Oh skank fest and there
you'll have a link for the 30 free
tickets 30 free - thank you I want to
thank you also for all the hard work
you've been doing on skank less oh this
makes it all worthwhile
I really appreciate you appreciating it
I knew you would anyway I was wondering
if um you showed your belt to the F guys
yet no re re no no no no hang up on this
guy no no no no it's rude can you be
more clear five six - hello you're on
we're right or left you can now write
you the refs of your game we're excited
about it's about to come out live on all
your social media hollow-cheeked
glendale go on five six - all right well
I just want to talk about you know I was
at the Dodger game on mushrooms a couple
times and I couldn't stop wondering how
great the ground crew was who knows what
goes on in the background you know when
you like sober because there's so many
things that you could pay there's a lot
of hot mexican chicks there's a lot of
drunk Mexican guys who by the way drunk
Mexicans love to get the wave going
that's all I know is you got and you're
like oh fights gonna break out some
point and then we just all get lung cuz
eventually sewing it's a home run and we
recalibrate and then it starts over it's
always that group of little kids in
left-field running back and forth in the
middle I'm trying to get below the way
of going yeah for sure
Dodger you think we all go back yeah
yeah welcome to hang up on our listeners
ah hello oh you hung up on that guy too
okay here we go you guys 404
or in the house how are you you're on
with Radar ruff ruff rating go to your
App Store it's soon to be out rate those
refs by the way you guys really want to
blow up if you really want to blow up
Pro Wrestling those guys are have you
guys seen the YouTube video of that like
excited boxing grass oh yeah I love it
love it
yeah I'd love to become a boxing ref I
think that'd be fun I always wanted to
repure the fight between you two yeah
Ahri won't fight me I already talked you
won't fight me
404 hi three one nine where's three one
nine three one nine is uh Iowa New York
home a pat melton home my pet
I'm actually since you guys are talking
about rep and I'm actually MMA judge Oh
at what level I mean what would
organizational ocol circuit and in and
around the Midwest I'm certified in ABC
States yeah let's just say the
cauliflowers Association
everybody's got cauliflower do you know
the chicks in Iowa think that sexy is
that weird did chicks in Iowa of
cauliflower quarter but cauliflower ear
oh not my wife do you know you know
where you gotta worry is when you hook
up with the chicken she has cauliflower
[ __ ] cuz that thing's been taking a
beating
cauliflower [ __ ] is that's that's a
chick that's been arrangers hey so uh
what do we think what do you want so
you're calling it what is the biggest
misconception do you think about what
people think of MMA refs about the wrath
yeah like everyone's like oh this guy's
an [ __ ] like it's not that easy
or the biggest thing that they that was
not easy
oh I'm sure I could have gone to what
the seminar I went to to get certified
to be a judge it was a two-day thing and
the other day was to be a ref but I
didn't want to be a rough like it's you
stop a fight too early then you're the
biggest piece of [ __ ]
yeah late you're a [ __ ] let me just say
that it's very easy but if you don't if
you can't do it you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
in here very specific that's pretty
specific I've always wanted that kind of
feedback
I've always want to know this about
about when you are being a judge now not
a referee but a judge in MMA how today
and when it when you get certified or
they train you what do they say about
defense and about bring control like if
you're pushing the pace how do you score
around and if you're get down before you
do if I if you shoot at me all the time
and I sprawl a lot and I constantly
defend and I wall walk and I don't get
taken down I feel like it's hard we've
always said that on this show they don't
score that properly okay sorry the way
that it broke down at the conference I
went to the seminar I went to so say
that was all that happened with shooting
and sprawling yes and sprawling yep the
guy who's shooting it that sounds like a
great horn around because they don't
give points for defense they give points
for the aggressive see that I've always
thought that talked about the fight
somewhere I always thought that's been
[ __ ] like if that was all that was
happening but like what I was taught
partner was effective striking expect
effective striking infective grappling
are the number one a one be their
example who is doing the most effective
of trying to advance and finish the
fight and do damage that's number one
and then after that you start looking at
okay well he was more aggressive maybe
they both landed about the same but he
was definitely pushing for more you know
then you start breaking it off my point
is I've always thought that it's been
backwards when if somebody is pushing
the pace and unsuccessfully grappling
and I am a good defensive
fighter and I'm successfully defending
you you get points for pushing the pace
and I don't get points for successfully
defending that yeah yeah I mean yeah and
I mean and I'll tell you like don't call
it point because you're not giving point
the light but it is to me like if you're
like that was a big day we cuz at that
seminar we would be like well would you
saw points for this and the guy would
like no you're not giving points but how
many people how many people were at your
seminar defense would do some damage to
you know defend that takedown pop a
couple on the way out they're gonna get
a lot more you know points per se but
yeah it's fine I did a show where the
main event ended in a draw well I was
hoping you were gonna say murder-suicide
I had a 10-9 one way another judge head
at ten nine the other way and then the
other judge saw it the same way as me
but had a 10-8 for the third round yeah
so it came out to a draw so what kind
what what real quick but what is it's
gotta be we've seen it before where refs
on the court or on the field and I'm not
sure maybe if it happens with judges as
well but it does does the atmosphere in
the arena the field affect you at all
like do people going crazy for some
strikes could you go okay home in a way
you know I mean does it affect it I mean
is there such thing let's be honest and
I'm not sure if you can actually answer
this but home cookin is this is home
cooking a real thing I'd imagine so I
mean I can't say like I don't know I
came up fighting with a lot of these
same guys now or at least the guys that
they trained with like I know everybody
a little bit and then I got out of
fighting and now I do this and I stay
involved and so like I don't know I I
get pretty tunnel vision but I could
absolutely
see that the hometown guy plant they
shot it for sure habits I'm sure those
things are endemic to all the sports
right I mean like rookie versus veteran
you know yeah come on Ari what if the
crowd goes crazy that must be like oh
that was better
yeah I'm sure yeah well the biggest
think that's more if you don't know what
you're watching though like well that
doesn't guy personally have a pretty
good base of watching a fight well the
big problem with boxing with uh with MMA
early was they were using boxing refs
who didn't understand grappling that was
very automatic for about five years
early on they know no idea what they
were doing
are you licensed through the state are
you licensed through the organization so
alright there's this guy Rob Hines oh
you might have seen him a ref on
Bellator yeah Rick Hill licensing goes
around does yeah so I went to his
seminar and it was I mean the test we
sat through a whole day of like classes
and stuff and these are two different
things he showed there's ten different
submissions in video clips and you had
to know what submission it was and so
like you know certain things like
anaconda Gator roll and sometimes don't
want none unless you've got buns hun and
then I done the written test you had to
get 80% to pass and only 10 of the 20
that were there passed God yeah all you
have to get is a low B and half the
people who's applying for this I know
you can't do any better than that you
[ __ ] shouldn't be judging are you do
you are you licensure to stay or through
whatever like cauliflower fighting he's
a big Rick the big Rick's ABC I think
it's dead the American boxing okay all
right so corporate is some sort of thing
all right something like this the ABC
states I stay right here and I look as
I'm just MMA so I've got to know some of
the promoters around here and I can work
every couple months
just do it for fun what's one thing Iowa
chicks are known for what are they known
for there we go high five one thread
what are gonna save in a new license
with okay powerful powerful punchy you
guys hey thanks for calling like an
excitement I have a feeling she's gonna
go bad okay go on
it's not Sam yeah I'm super happy to
have you back this week thank you I've
not been able to listen live I don't
know what the resolution is I can't wait
to hear the iTunes tomorrow but the
number one person I wanted to call in
was because of last week's episode with
bass exhale
I immediately purchased that thing thank
you it's great use my podcast with an
hour and it was here in three [ __ ]
days
yeah oh great I really loved it how hard
you are so high right now we hear the
wind blowing from the bottom just we're
talking about life buddy we love you to
death thanks for calling in I just I
can't take the windsock there's a hurry
oh [ __ ]
take a hit to take a hit it's right
behind you don't wind up that one I I
think that's what it is yeah that
thing's great
I was just high like the rest of the day
yeah it's a great body huh yeah what's a
promo code use the code go to vape
exhale use the code punch-drunk
and it gets you it saves you almost 50
bucks on that thing and it really is the
best vape I've ever used I'm not even a
big vape guy but that thing's legit like
I was cool
I don't know but I'd love to find out
yeah yeah it's called a [ __ ] crack
pipe what are you doing sir what now I
was talking to Sam ah welcome you're on
the air with punch-drunk how can we help
you
[ __ ] what how are you buddy what what's
up
not much just here in snow we asked
Minnesota like that other guy a couple
couple minutes to go got a minute
building this Willie quick sure go for
it Jason Tebow had one of the best sets
I've ever seen in comedy a couple weeks
ago no do is that spoiler alerts comedy
club oh wow the annihilation were the
lady and her husband both her and a
ghost in the [ __ ] White House okay
yes hilarious yeah I spoil a lot of the
best bit
I've seen it blew my [ __ ] [ __ ] jockey
that's very well done yeah that was uh
that was a great that was a great set
that I had also uh I was at spoiler
alert and I watched uh that Garry
Shandling thing he dies at the end the
Garry Shandling documentary so spoiler
alert there - boiler lurtz I saw that
I'm watching that now first one or the
second one
you know the Garry Shandling one yeah
I'm saying are you on the first one or
the second one okay it's great second
one's better first one's great I want to
see because the thing about Garry
Shandling that's so amazing is how long
it took for him to make it like he
couldn't get anything going for over ten
years
well stand up but I mean he was hit with
writing shows I mean he was writing
Sanford and Son guys and all that [ __ ]
right yeah yeah two five three you are
about three Carla New York the ref
rating app rate your F my question is
okay there we go guys we love you call
in on a line that works don't beat a
wind tunnel
don't be food don't be drop the word
[ __ ] on us because we are in a wind
tunnel and I'm busy trying to get
through it by eating hamburger meat what
should I be calling or wait wait wait
wait until you get home oh you know wait
just wait wait
or interested or just shove a hot dog up
your ass whatever you want
ah we anymore no more callers as you
mentioned to not just rating the apps
but not just rating the refs but
chatting with your friends we have the
tailgate app so like we're talking on
this [ __ ]
to each other about MMA about calls
about the Raiders or the Rams and all
that but you can create these tailgates
within the app itself
you don't need to get watching let's say
that that that baseball game or that
football game or that basket but it's
all the people watching it you know
Clippers in the playoffs you know you
know it'd be great if you teamed up with
grinder put that on there and then
together like guys could [ __ ] their
friends while they rate the rest we're
gonna share your your team status yeah
Clippers have AIDS 302 haha look was
almost out of the playoffs the pelicans
are down to the last [ __ ] seed one
game above Denver after losing four
straight this is gonna come out of the
[ __ ] wire where the Pels can make the
playoffs for them I'm telling you
something and I don't want the Clippers
make fun we want rut I want high pitch
dude I mean dude that piston picks
looking like it could get real I mean
dude I want one of the good guys here's
the thing
Golden's I'm saying it right now golden
Saint does not win a World Championship
this year Houston or even more likely
Toronto [ __ ] they shoot their pants
in the plan but dude I'm telling you the
team to watch and nobody's talking about
Portland dude cuz they have everything
you need to win a champion three
all-star level players one franchise
player and two cold-blooded assassins
who can hit the shop when the screws are
getting tight that's what you need to
win a champion depth on their thing they
got tons of guys who could shoot
everything Portland isn't dude gold
Saint with the game Portland the second
[ __ ] round that's a bet I know income
six games but that's about it
you don't think so [ __ ] up this time
dude this is a bad hey buddy
this is a Christian podcast and that
link which won't be tolerant okay okay
what do you want people what a fighting
yeah what your favorite part out what
favorite what party skank week oh you
were saying when we were out here yeah
okay John here two guys going once the
podcast was great I'd funded to show the
park
the guy hang up on the other guy we go
302 welcome where's 302 Delaware
Delaware's that still estate what am i
one of my favorite places I've ever
bombed how are you welcome to punch
trunk what do you want to talk about I
talk about the fix of possibly won the
championship this year
ah I don't know if they quit now marques
faults is a [ __ ] real deal
that guy's the real deal he can't shoot
he can't play he's playing yeah he's
actually playing pretty good you're just
gonna bring that point up for [ __ ]
five months I gotta hear out this guy's
on his deathbed he may never walk again
he can't raise his left arm and then he
finally comes back and he's lighting it
up dude how does it go from one to the
other
hey what's up put the kids down we want
to talk to them about the importance of
roughs and vaping so get him up get a
mom real quick I think that's one of
your challenges you got a young team and
you're gonna have refs aren't gonna give
him any love yeah kleavon gonna get
somebody to good point and and they're
just not gonna get to loving me driving
down they're gonna be hey real quick
before we bring in three two three real
quick six one nine what do you want
hey what's course and me calling in from
the chill-out zone okay chill dawg chill
zone you got a chill you got a cool off
he's gonna go off cool down cool down
real quick what's up thanks bud hey what
do you think of Marquette King I'm a
piss that they dropped him I'm pissed
that they dropped him to punch the curve
yeah I'm pissed that they dropped and we
didn't have to joining us on the
celebrity a hotline brought to you by
bet DSi
the bet DSi celebrity hotline I believe
it is the one and only who is it three
two three fight who is it dice it's
Andrew Dice Clay everybody welcome dice
is it true that Ari was rifling to your
affairs at one point in time what are
you so upset about you
you fire it up right now I don't even
have to re not even the ball feed him
already long [ __ ] you've never brought
the sledgehammer out usually it's about
what Sebastian we're talking about right
I called my friend Gallagher and I'm
gonna get the bet with you actually
asked for permission to use Gallagher's
sledgehammer yeah why what's going on
why what where did this come from all
this anger and sebastian but confirm the
real italian oh really but but i thought
you're actually jewish guy on the road i
teach him how to wear the black jeans in
the well yeah do you think you could say
what you're saying is you think you
created a monster dice I think I created
a baby mm-hmm
now is there any part of you that feels
like I don't know maybe like a little I
don't want to say jealous but you know
maybe you created this and he's not
giving you credit you gotta take him
down so would it what are you gonna do -
take him down dice let's talk strategy
he can still do stand-up but he would
just be in a wheelchair
sit down comedy that's what he's gonna
be doing so how can we how can you know
because either I love Sebastiao good
friend of mine for a long time you're my
friend how can we find resolution dice
what do we got to do like a dice off
maybe when I stop would be good you get
the cage you call Bruce Buffer
and I kill him in a cage
you guys enjoy a question here
sure of course dice you know I've always
been a big fan of yours and so you know
it's with respect that I asked this but
what do you say about the theory that's
out there that Sebastian is wearing it
better
I can't even I'm looking at the answer
in this question he's wearing it better
than the dice no no how many times did
you text Sebastian they didn't hit you
back that's borderline that's borderline
stalking dice now I understand that
you're so worried about and angry about
Sebastian that you've actually been
training MMA and that you've been
training with George st. Pierre is that
true training me but I'm always trained
to the throw hand and what Sebastian is
not training nothing he's just training
to do more of this Seinfeld joke I'm
coming for him and it's not gonna be
pretty
dice okay so you don't want to say who
you're training with but is your trainer
there can we talk to your trainer if
he's there you don't have to say his
name
okay Wheelz is training dice this sounds
one really but wheels I didn't know you
even had any knowledge of mixed martial
arts in Thailand in Thailand huh oh so
you're saying yeah oh wow wow wow wow
wow
I'll cue take us kind of through some of
what what your fights were like in
Thailand I'd love to hear this yeah
actually he fought in the tourney
oh I mean how did you kill him by the
way how'd you
they blinded me with that powder and
then what and questioned me the groin in
the Wow so blinded by powder then you go
to your classic blinded move splits
groin punch
[Laughter]
can you put ice back on real quick
wheels can we bring you guys together
and figure this out nice we can have you
guys fight with each other you're all
comedy store we got bring people
together make love you know not war yeah
Andrew I'm sorry I just got this text I
was trying to text Sebastian while we
were doing this so I could see if I can
get some hints from him about like you
know filly just I just want him to like
show us respect the answer I got back is
I'm sorry to have to be the one to read
this out loud oh man I'm sorry have to
bring this to you but I just redid you
oh [ __ ] that guy
he only pay me a hundred bucks a show to
open for him at giant stadiums it was it
was more it was more worth for me to
work my job at the hotel
would be too open for dice he didn't do
anything for me he used me [ __ ] him oh
Jesus
know why I'm not sure can we we see the
text sorry I don't know how to flip it
on my screen okay dice what's your reply
to that you know why I wasn't paying
okay well I mean I just hope you guys
get together
why can't Anna and Armenian I mean I
like Ana an Italian and a Jew come
together and then Italian Jew and
Italian Jew come together why did you
try to go by one name where do you learn
that from last name
I think it's cos no nice fellas last
name play Andrew Dice Clay you have a
first name a nickname and the last name
so it's not from what about Jesus maybe
before you re that that was wonderful
podcast for the tree thanks guys
guys thanks for calling and what can
what can it be anybody can get involved
in how can they get involved in beta
testing or anything like that or wind is
gonna drop how can people find the app
yeah and you know one last feature if
you're a degenerate gambler we've got
we've got odds we've got you know how
accurate Vegas has been on on all these
games to spread you know so you can go
to WWF ratings comm just click on the
contact area and you can sign up to be
part of the beta testing team school and
then once you sign up you will get a
welcome email and an invitation from
Apple to download their app called test
flight and then that's basically kind of
think of it like an app store yeah where
you'll be able to download reference
from yeah it's real easy all we need is
an email the download is really quickly
it's really quick and we've got
promotional offers we've got two box
level seats for the Dodgers for people
who are in this first pool joining until
we got those we got say well you guys
say App Store you're talking about the
application store is that correct yes I
know kind of flip phone doesn't know
that hi walk you through it out there
but yeah we've got this first promotion
we're gonna have more following after
that high chances to win re final
thoughts guys I'm gonna send a shout out
real quick so you don't show the Notre
Dame women's basketball team that was I
tried to get her to call him but she
said no because already and we're gonna
make fun of me the whole time oh did she
really say that I'll show you the text
no I wouldn't do that my feelings I know
but anyways we I just wanna say congrats
my mother's had Notre Dame season
tickets for a long time women's
basketball it's the only sport she cares
about and they want to champ ship in an
extremely exciting fashion yeah so I was
very very happy for them and I'm very
happy for her and congratulations Notre
Dame knows exciting that's way more
exciting than immense oh I love anytime
Connecticut loses I think they're bad
for bass and Jeannot Jeannot loses Annie
if this is a male version he would have
moved on the NBA and if he dominated the
NBA he would retire and just do circuit
now he's just you know the problem is is
that the women's basketball the real
league is in Russia and they just can't
[ __ ] get anything there's no money in
the pro league here guys this has been
puncturing sports hey this Saturday come
down to the Sycamore tavern for the Live
come on fight with us come watch play
with all of us we'll be there
all right you guys are gee thanks coming
up guys